in 2018 machines that can read your face
will go mainstream changing the way we
live your face will become your password
unlocking smartphones and bank accounts
face recognition 2018 will change our
lives but the technology will also have
the power to covertly track your
movements moving into a world where
machines can follow you around and
characterising based only on your face
is worrying because it potentially
limits your freedom he will even be able
to guess your sexuality through facial
features alone in 2018 we'll be forced
to face the future the human face has an
astonishing variety of features which
not only help us recognize others but
read and understand them through a
constant flow of intentional and
unintentional signals it's one of the
unique functions that separates man from
machine until now 2018 is going to be a
landmark year for face recognition
because there has been a huge amount of
progress in the underlying technology
known
machine learning and what that allows
you to do is pull a very accurate face
print out of a photograph that uniquely
identifies a person pioneering facial
recognition technology hasn't yet hit
the mainstream in 2018 it will be in our
pockets
facial recognition is going to go
mainstream in 2018 largely because the
latest iPhone has face recognition
technology built into it you look at it
and it recognizes you by next year
there'll be millions of those devices
out in the world and they're gonna get
used to unlocking our phone then we're
gonna start getting used to getting into
our banking apps with face recognition
and it's gonna start feeling normal but
using your face to unlock your phone is
just the beginning in the suburbs of
Israel's financial center Tel Aviv a
team of engineers is at the forefront of
a technological revolution we invented
simple way of transforming a photo into
text they're teaching machines to read
faces the face recognition model can
measure the distance between your eyes
the width of your lips the distance from
your lips to nose etc at the end of that
process we are left with a simple text
which is the basis of our recognition
the software has the power to identify
one face from millions in under one
second our accuracy under controlled
environment is around 99 percent and
it's this precision that makes the
technology an effective new tool for
surveillance
we can identify people without them
knowing that they are being identified
we have clients ranging from medical
centers retail chain stores churches
retail stores are using this technology
to generate data on customers tracking
their shopping habits and targeting
in-store adverts churches are even using
facial recognition to monitor attendance
and one school in the UK wants to use it
to keep tabs on teachers we have one
school where teachers took too long
breaks therefore the management decided
to put them on the watch list but
there's one country that's ahead of the
game China is a harbinger of the future
for this kind of technology companies
have access to a government image
database of 700 million people half its
population China is already using this
widely in security looking for
terrorists or people who have warrants
out for their arrest but they're also
using it to let people pay in fast-food
restaurants to access theme parks
without having to buy a ticket and even
bizarrely to try and catch people whose
deloo paper from public toilets but
there's the potential for more sinister
applications researchers have shown that
your face can point to your sexuality
it's not gonna mean you can take a photo
of someone and get a yes-or-no gay or
straight
but what it does mean is that if a bad
actor or an authoritarian regime gathers
say 10,000 pictures and asks which of
the 10 people are most likely to be gay
they're quite likely to get many of
those right this new ability to record
store and analyze images of faces on a
vast scale will fundamentally change
notions of privacy fairness and trust
2018 the most contact that people will
have with face recognition they won't
actually know necessarily it'll be
through security services it'll be
through shops that are profiling you and
that's with the more worrying side of it
but tech companies are forging ahead
with their plans to make facial
recognition and everyday part of our
lives
you cannot stop progress and the fear of
privacy the advantages of security of
business information are far greater
than some privacy
this technology is a new kind of power
and the only way we have of dealing with
technologies currently is to make
regulations that repress bad uses and
allow for the perceived good uses 2018
will be a year or we start to work out
what some of those are
[Music]
you
you